[MUSIC PLAYING]
MYLES BORINS: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for
joining us today.
How are you doing?
Today, we're going
to be talking to you
about growing your app on GCP.
First, I'd like
to introduce Aja.
Aja is a developer advocate.
Aja loves Ruby, dinosaurs,
robots, and, of course, cats.
AJA HAMMERLY: And this is Myles.
Myles is developer advocate
on the Cloud team with me.
And he's also the director of
the Node.js Technical Steering
Committee.
And he loves music and getting
dim sum with his tech friends.
In fact, earlier this week,
we stumbled across dim sum
randomly on the Google campus.
And we had to
pause our rehearsal
so we could have dumplings
before we could continue.
MYLES BORINS: I ate them all.
AJA HAMMERLY: So we've part
of our careers at startups,
for both of us.
We know what it's like taking
an idea into production
and then growing it and adapting
it as your user base shifts.
We know that picking
the right tools
for the job at the right
time is a balancing
act of costs versus
benefits versus skill sets.
And today, we're
here to show you
that the Google Cloud
Platform has products
that will work for you, no
matter what phase you are at
and what your current
struggles are.
MYLES BORINS: So once upon
a time, there was a startup.
Cat Facts.
Has anyone heard of
Cat Facts before?
Raise of hands.
There's a few of you.
AJA HAMMERLY: We
might be old, Myles.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah.
This might be an old joke.
Cat Facts is a service for
getting facts about cats.
AJA HAMMERLY: So some quick
facts about our Cat Facts app.
We already have an MVP.
We're running on some
provider somewhere,
in a VM, because originally
were running on my laptop.
And we've got some OS.
And the database
and the app are all
running in that
environment, because that's
how I had it on my laptop.
And we're using
node, because Myles.
some noSQL database,
because I don't want
to deal with having
to keep a schema consistent and
having to deal with the schema
as we're rapidly
iterating on this thing.
And we're doing
email integration
through a third party, because
I don't want to deal with email.
MYLES BORINS: So like
cats, the VMs that we use
are a little temperamental.
We only have one at a time.
It's very precious.
But it also can
get kind of angry,
if you try to pet
it too quickly.
And we really have
to take care of it.
There's no real room when you
have a single virtual machine
for errors.
AJA HAMMERLY: So Myles
is going to show us quick
what the MVP looks like,
because most of you
are not familiar with the
joy that is Cat Facts.
So as you can see here,
we have Cat Facts.
You're can sign up for Cat
Facts with your email address.
I'm going to make one
up ohmygodcats.biz.
We're going to submit it.
Now, once we've submitted it,
we've subscribed to Cat Facts.
We're going to get
a response letting
us know that we have
successfully subscribed.
And then, every
single day, we're
going to get an email with
a new fact and a new cat,
with a new cat fact.
Back to you, Aja.
MYLES BORINS: Thanks, Myles.
So are our Cat Facts app
wants to move to the cloud.
And we're going to be using
GCP, because we're here
at Google I/O. So
what are the reasons
folks might want to move
to the cloud and to GCP?
One of the ones I hear a lot
is that people's investors
want them to.
Investors are familiar
with the cloud
and they know that it gives
you a lot of flexibility
to grow rapidly if you're
app just suddenly takes off.
And it's also
relatively easy to get
an idea of what costs will be.
The cloud is known and people
are comfortable with it now.
You might also want
to move to the cloud
because you don't
have an ops team.
Our Cat Facts app, it's
just the two of us.
We don't really
have an ops team.
And you might want to move to
GCP, because you trust Google.
You know that GCP is
running on the same hardware
and the same data
centers where we run
YouTube and Search and Gmail.
And we keep those up.
So we should be able to
keep your app up too.
So we have a VM.
To run VMs on GCP, we're going
to be using Google Compute
Engine.
This is Google's VMs
on the cloud service.
And we can pick that exact
combination of CPU and RAM
that's right for
serving our Cat Facts.
And so I'm going
to pick something
that looks like my dev box,
because I know that works.
MYLES BORINS: So if we want to
move a VM over to Google Cloud
Platform, there's a
couple of different ways
that we can do it.
We can spin up a whole fresh
VM and maintain it by hand
and build everything up.
Or we can try to find a
way to orchestrate it.
This can be through tools such
as Ansible, Chef, or Puppet.
Or you can have file system
images that you move over.
But it is going to be a manual
process to move this over.
So VMs are awesome, though.
And there's a lot of things
that I like about VMs.
You have really
fast startup time.
So you could see from the
second that you spin up the VM,
it's going to be about
30 seconds until it's
available and ready to use.
And once it's running, it's
available all the time.
You don't have to worry
about how fast it's
going to boot up after that.
From that you can make
images and quickly boot up
in the future at any time.
You can also
customize the specs.
You can customize how much
memory you're going to have,
how much CPU you're
going to have.
And you could really dial it in.
If you need graphics
cards, you can do that.
If you need to TPUs for doing
TensorFlow, you can do that.
It's extremely flexible.
You can make it as big
or small as you want.
And it's very familiar.
So if you know the Ubuntu
environment or Windows Server,
you can just get
that spun up quickly
and be working in an
environment that you know.
AJA HAMMERLY: So there's a
list of stuff to consider here.
We have to consider
process management,
security updates, upgrades.
We need to consider scaling.
We have to be
responsible for doing
all of those security patches.
If something bad happens--
I don't know how
many of you guys
were working in the industry
when Heartbleed happened,
but I was working
consulting at that point.
And that was a very
frantic morning for us,
as we patched a
whole bunch of VMs.
You also, if you're dealing with
VMs, you have to do backups.
You have disaster
recovery and provisioning.
And you have to do
database replication.
And that's always been my
least favorite ops task,
is database replication.
And our ops team is
just the two of us.
And we don't have the time to
deal with all of that stuff.
So we're going to move to
highly managed services.
And specifically, I want
to start with the database.
Because I really don't want
to do database replication.
So we're going to move
to one of Google's types
of managed databases,
where we can get services
like that and some of our
disaster recovery taken
care of for us.
Google has SQL
and noSQL options.
We specifically have Cloud
SQL in our relational model.
And we support both MySQL
school and PostgreSQL.
And if you have something
that's very high throughput,
you need to do a lot of writes.
You need consistency.
And you need to be global scale.
We have Cloud Spanner,
which is amazing.
It can do so much stuff.
And it almost violates the
cap theorem, but not quite.
And then, we have data storage,
which is our noSQL option.
That's actually what we're
going to be using in this demo.
And then, we also have Fire
Store, which not on the slide
but is part of Firebase and
is very similar to data store.
MYLES BORINS: So now that we
have the database moved over,
we want to figure out where
to run the application.
How many people in the audience
have used App Engine before?
Raise of hands.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
MYLES BORINS: Awesome.
So you know all the
amazing benefits
about moving to App Engine.
But App Engine is our managed
platform as a service.
We love App Engine,
because there's no ops.
It has integrated data store.
When you deploy on App Engine,
you have HTTPS already ready
for you.
You have idiomatic runtime.
So I love this, as
a Node.js developer.
I can write my Node.js app.
I can test it locally.
And then, I can deploy
it to the Cloud.
It's going to run exactly the
way that I expect it to run.
And if I need to run
it somewhere else,
it's going to just work.
Also, all of the
container images
that we use for App Engine Flex
are all available on GitHub.
So if you want to fork them,
if you want to add to them,
it's easy for you to do that.
AJA HAMMERLY: So now,
we've got someone else
dealing with the
operations of our app.
And we'd demo for
you, but the demo
for showing it running an App
Engine is nothing's changed.
So we're going to
skip that part.
So now, we can factor
out bits of our app
and add new features,
which is what
I, as an application developer,
really want to be doing.
I want to make cool stuff.
I don't want to
deal with pagers.
So first thing we're
going to pull out
is our app mails you Cat Facts.
And we don't really have to
run the mailer in the front-end
on the same machine.
So Myles is going to tell
us about what we're going
to do next with the mailer.
MYLES BORINS: So
when we originally
wrote this application
for MVP, as we said,
we had everything in a VM.
The database was in the VM.
The single node
app did everything.
And this isn't super flexible.
It's not going to scale nicely.
It's not going to have
nice abstractions.
And it's not going
to be reusable.
So one of the first things that
we decided to abstract out,
once we moved over
to App Engine,
was our Cat Facts as a service.
So we were able
to go and maybe--
Aja, do you want to get
into and describe it?
AJA HAMMERLY: So what
we're going to do here
is I'm going to show you--
so we moved all of our stuff
to Cloud Functions,
like Myles said.
And we moved a mailer.
And we also moved some
other stuff there.
But the first thing
we needed to do
was to build out a function
to get us Cat Facts.
So this is some code to retrieve
Cat Facts from the database
and a picture to go with it.
You can see, we're just doing
some really basic data store
queries here.
And we're ordering
on last year's, only
pulling one thing back, and
I've got some code there
to update a time stamp.
And then, we just send back
a very basic JSON payload
and a status code of 200.
It really took only about 10
minutes to write this code.
And most of that was remembering
how data store and JavaScript
worked together.
And Myles was talking
about the e-mails.
So he's going to go into
the code for the email
and talk a little bit
about how we approach that.
MYLES BORINS: So
part of the reason
why we decided to move the
emailer to a Cloud Function
was because email is
not a service that
is running in hot code.
It's not going to necessarily
affect the user experience.
And you saw the demo
where I signed up
with my email address.
I want to get the response
from the server giving me
the confirmation
that I've signed up.
We do that once your email
addresses in data store.
But once that's
done, we don't need
to wait for an email to
go out to actually send
a confirmation to the user.
So we send a message out on
Pub/Sub to send an email.
And we have this generic email
server that creates a client
and sends a request
with the data,
to, that's who the
email is going to,
from, that's who is e-mailing
it, the subject, and the body.
And this can be actually reused
throughout our application.
So the exact same
Cloud Function is
running to send an email
when you subscribe.
And it's also sending an
email every single day,
whenever new facts go out.
And by splitting it out
into a Cloud Function,
it's able to scale
up with our load
as we have more
people subscribing.
It's able to be used
for different things.
And it's able to be
its own code that we
can think about independently.
And if we ever want to change
our email service, for example,
we could just change
the Cloud Function.
As long as we adhere to the same
API, the rest of the services
don't need to change at all.
AJA HAMMERLY: And so we talked
about adding new features.
And one of the things
I wanted to add
was a Cat Facts bot, because
I really like chat bots.
They're a lot of fun.
And our team uses Hangouts
Chat, which is super cool.
And so I've written
a Hangouts Chat bot.
And one of the
interesting things
is that both the
mailer and the bot
use the same underlying
Cat Facts service.
And all the Hangouts Chat bot
does is it reformats the fact
and picture a
payload into the form
that Hangouts Chat requires.
All I have to do is call out
to the Cat Facts service,
get a fact back, and
then send back a 200
with the JSON package the
exact way that the Hangouts
Chat expects it.
And I had a chat bot.
It was really fast
and really easy.
And because it's running in
Cloud Functions, if 100,000
people hit my Hangouts Chat
bot to get their Cat Facts
at the same time, it's fine.
And if no one's using
my Cat Facts chat
bot, because no one wants
cat facts right now,
that's also fine.
Cloud Functions will
scale automatically
to what I need at the time.
And so I really
liked it, because I
don't know if Cat Facts
is going to take off.
Maybe people don't want cat
facts in their chat bots.
But Myles is going
to actually show you
that chat bot right now.
And you guys are going to
see pictures of my cats.
MYLES BORINS: So here you can
see, we are in Hangouts Chat.
And we've got a chat
going with the bot.
And I could go like,
hey, bot, give me a cat.
And the bot's is going to
think about it for a second.
It's making a call to
the Cloud Function.
It's getting the data
from the Cloud Function.
It comes back with
a cat and a fact,
that each cat and owner have
their own unique vocabulary.
And we can message it again,
hey, more cats [? plx. ?]
And we give it a second to think
about a new cat and a new fact.
And it gets back to us--
argh-- with the same
cat and the same fact.
And that's how you know
that this is a real demo.
Back to you, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: So what happened
there is I had a time out.
I did not actually officially
put enough time in my chat bot
to do the update on my query,
because we're trying to pull
the least recently used.
I spent some time
debugging that yesterday.
But I'm sorry that you guys
saw the broken version.
But you know it's real.
So Myles is going talk a little
bit about the architecture
that we ended up with.
And then, we're going
to talk about one
of the last compute options
you have available on GCP.
MYLES BORINS: So we've
been talking through all
these different services.
But we thought that this diagram
would kind of give a clear idea
of how we architected it.
So we have a front-end
that's written
in Node.js and Express, that's
running on App Engine, that's
taking user requests.
And when you sign up, it's
adding a user to big table.
And then, it's
requesting a cat fact
from the Cat Fact function.
And then, it's submitting
an event to Pub/Sub
to let it know to send an email.
Pub/Sub is then
triggering the function
that's listening for new email
events and emailing it out.
Now, the Task Scheduler
is another App Engine app.
If you didn't know, you
can actually make Cron jobs
using App Engine to set it up to
execute App Engine REST calls,
based on certain
amounts of time.
So the Task Scheduler's set
to run on a daily basis.
Every single day, it gets
the list of all the people
who have subscribed.
And then, it sets a new
task in the Pub/Sub queue
for every single person
to send them a new fact.
The emailer goes and grabs
the cat fact and sends it out.
What's really cool
about this, too, though,
is you'll notice that we have
multiple services calling
to the Cat Facts service.
So we have the chat bot,
which is also calling
to the Cat Facts service.
And we could build a whole
fleet of services regarding
Cat Facts, depending
on the kind of service
you want to use to use it.
We can make e-mailers,
SMS, chat bots, IRC bots.
And they can all use
the same microservice
that can scale up, based
on how much load there is.
Maybe we find out that people
don't like email anymore
and we need to pivot to SMS.
We're ready to do that.
And we don't have to
do much refactoring
to our actual architecture
in order to support that.
AJA HAMMERLY: So at
this point, let's
just pretend that Cat
Facts is the new hotness
and it is wildly
successful and we
have hundreds of millions of
users getting their cat facts
and cat pictures
on a daily basis.
So if that happens, which
we hope will happen,
we're going to be
able to hire someone
to help us with operations.
And when I've talked to my
friends who work in operations,
one of them said that we need
to consider Google Kubernetes
engine.
I was talking to
her about it and she
said that it would give
us more flexibility
with our architecture,
while retaining
many of the benefits of App
Engine and Cloud Functions.
And it would specially
work well for us,
because we've already moved
toward a microservices
architecture, with a bunch of
different scalable components.
MYLES BORINS: So
you may be asking
yourself, what's a Kubernetes?
How many people in the audience
have used Kubernetes so far?
AJA HAMMERLY: OK.
MYLES BORINS: So you're not
asking what's a Kubernetes?
But for those who haven't,
Kubernetes is the Greek word,
I believe, for helmsmen.
AJA HAMMERLY: Governor,
helmsmen, one of those.
I don't remember which.
MYLES BORINS: And it is a
service that's open sourced.
It's in the CNCF, the Cloud
Native Compute Foundation.
And it's for orchestrating
and scaling Docker containers
in production.
It's a way of setting
up Cloud architecture.
And it's designed and
based on the Google
internal architecture work.
So a lot of the
lessons and things
that we've learned about
making scalable services
were all used to inspire the
architecture of Kubernetes.
On our next slide, we're going
to show what a YAML file looks
like for Kubernetes.
And Aja's going tell
you all about that.
AJA HAMMERLY: So Here's an
example Kubernetes deployment
file for and Nginx container.
The big thing to be aware
of with Kubernetes--
and this is the thing that a
lot of folks find challenging
at first--
is that unlike when
you're signing up VMs
and you're doing scripting to
make your VMs reproducible,
all of that's
focused on the how.
You want to install this
thing and then this thing.
And then, you want to
change these ports.
And you want to set up
this kind of load balancer.
Kubernetes, you need to describe
what a happy, wonderful, good
state is for your product.
This many versions
of this container.
This kind of load balancer.
And then, what Kubernetes
does for you is it
does everything in its power
to keep that happy state.
So if one of your nodes
magically, one of your VM
gets hit by lightning in
the center of your center--
it could happen--
Kubernetes will take what
was running on that VM,
on that node, and it will
put it to other places,
in a way to make
sure that your app is
as close to that running
state, that happy state
that you want it to be.
And it takes a little bit
of work for a lot of people
to get their head
around the fact
that you don't explain
how to get there.
You use the concepts that
are built into Kubernetes,
pods, services, deployments,
to describe what a successfully
running app looks like.
So Myles mentioned it a bit.
In that example, I was
actually using the Nginx Docker
container.
What's a Docker, was
one of the things
that I asked when
people were trying
to teach me about Kubernetes.
And it is a container format.
And a container is a
way of packaging up
runtime and the files and the
dependencies to go with it.
And the nice thing about it is
you can put multiple of them
on a VM.
And you don't have to deal
with dependency conflicts.
Like I know when I was working
in ops, one of the things
we had was we had, like, three
different parts of the service,
different microservices.
And they each were using
slightly different versions
of various Ruby gems or slightly
different versions of various C
libraries.
And installing them together,
side by side, was a problem.
And then, we had to get like
three different dev teams
to actually agree
on which version
we were going to standardize on.
With Docker, you
could just package up
an app with its dependencies
and run it next to an app
with slightly different,
or very different,
dependencies on
the same machine.
And you get much
better utilization.
And you get safety.
The other nice thing about
using containers and Docker is
that, since you're
packaging a container,
you seem to have less
problems with the works in dev
doesn't work in prod
situation, which
I know I've spent many hours
banging my head against.
And when you read
about this, you're
going to see stuff about
namespaces and cgroups and all
that.
But the big thing is
running application
with its dependencies
and its file
system all packaged up neatly.
MYLES BORINS: So what you
can see up on the screen
now is a fairly
straightforward Docker file.
We're starting from an image
that's actually published
by the Node.js project.
Carbon is the 8.x
branch for LTS.
And if you go from
Node.js carbon-alpine.
What that means is we're going
to grab the latest published
version of 8.x of Node running
on an Alpine-based operating
system.
And Alpine is a very,
very thin operating system
that's been designed
specifically for running
in Docker containers.
If you're looking for fast
boots and thin images,
Alpine is a good
place to get started.
We're copying the file
system from the folder
that we're running in
directly into the image.
We're going to run the command,
NPM install production.
That production flag makes sure
that you're dev dependencies
don't get installed.
And it's important to
run all of the commands
to set up your environment
before you're actually
running in production.
So this is going to make sure
that all the dependencies you
need are there, that there's
nothing in that image
that you don't need for
running in production.
Then, the command NPM start is
going to boot everything up.
So that command gets run
when the Docker container
is started.
NPM start is a really great
way to boot things up.
It's something you put in
your package JSON script.
If anyone has more questions
about kind of best practices
for setting up
node applications,
please feel free to
grab me after the talk.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
one of the things
I mentioned in my definition
of Docker is cgroups.
And you might be
thinking, what's a cgroup?
And that's out of
scope for this talk.
So you can come talk.
There's containers,
office hours,
and there's also office hours
on Google Clouds Open Source
projects in the
office hours space.
And folks from the
Kubernetes project
will be there, if you
want to talk in detail
about the implementation.
So why would you make
the switch to Kubernetes?
This is the question I get the
most when I'm out in the field
talking to folks at events
or I'm at dev ops meetups.
And the first thing I want
to say is you don't have to.
There's a lot of folks
out there who are like,
Kubernetes is the new hotness.
I have to use Kubernetes.
And if what you have
works for you, great.
App Engine, Cloud Functions,
or VMs or any combination
of those, like we had
with our Cat Facts app,
they're a fine way to run
your app indefinitely.
If it works, don't fix it.
But containers provide
some advantages
around portability,
predictability,
and utilization.
And I've seen a lot
of success with teams
that have switched to this.
The big thing that I've
seen from my dev ops friends
is that they're getting better
utilization out of their VMs.
They're able to use all of
the CPU and all of the memory
that they provision.
It's less of an issue with GCP,
because Google Compute Engine
lets you specify and make custom
VMs that exactly fit your app.
But if you have things that
are really variable in load
or you've got a
bunch of VMs that all
look the same, for
whatever reason,
containers might be a way
to solve that problem.
And if you've decided
to go with containers
for any of these
or other reasons,
Kubernetes is a great way
to manage the bin packing
problem of putting things
there and making sure
that everything stays up.
I really like that if you
specify known good state,
it will take care of making
that known good state maintained
for you, even if
something weird happens
to some of your machines.
MYLES BORINS: So some
concluding thoughts
about all of the things
that we just said.
Google Cloud Platform is kind
of like a delicious dim sum
buffet.
And bear with me on this.
You have lots of
different options.
And you can pick them all
depending on your tastes.
As you need more, they're there.
They're on the cart.
They're steamed.
They're ready to go.
You need more shu mai.
We've got more shu mai.
And it's really easy to share.
You have big projects,
you can add more people
to the projects.
They can grab the
dumplings they want.
Aja, now, I'm really hungry.
AJA HAMMERLY: Almost lunchtime.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, as you can
tell, I think almost as much
about dumplings as I
think about compute.
But I also like to
not have to think
about how I make the dumplings.
I just want to eat them.
And that really becomes
one of the great benefits
about using a
platform like this.
If you need to
focus on your MVP,
if you need to
focus on the product
that you're getting
out of the door
and your product
isn't operations,
you may want to be just
using all these things that
are ready to go.
You can iterate off
of them as necessary.
And you can make
architecture decisions
to make sure that you are
not super locked into things
that are harder to move.
But we have a lot of different
products available for you
today to run your compute in
all sorts of different ways
based on your needs.
AJA HAMMERLY: So we went through
a lot of stuff really quickly.
And one of the things I want
to make sure everyone knows
is that if you choose
one of these things,
it doesn't mean you can't
change your mind later on.
All of these things
play well together.
Projects that use a
lot of them are here.
Here's kind of the
high-level summary
of what we just talked about.
So we've got Google Compute
Engine, virtual machines
in custom sizes.
I was talking to someone
and they had done the math
and there's over 6,000
ways, I think, to configure,
6,000 different flavors of VM.
This is good when you are
already familiar with VMs.
Who's shipped something on a VM?
I know I have lots
and lots of times.
Wow.
That's actually fewer
folks than I expected.
Or if you just want
to pick up something
that you're running in a
VM on your local machine
and shove it into production.
We have Google App Engine.
This is a serverless
application platform.
It's good when you want a no
ops solution to running your app
and you want fully
managed services.
You want networking
taking care of.
You want autoscaling.
You want the ability to use
images that are known good
that Google has
endorsed and we're
making sure we're maintaining.
We're making sure we're
patching and things like that.
We've got Google Cloud Functions
for event-driven serverless
applications or for event-driven
parts of your application.
This is good for tasks that
need high scale some of the time
and are largely stateless.
It's especially good
if you have something
that you need to run a lot at
once and not a lot later on,
because you can shove as
much through that pipe as you
need to, or as little.
It depends on what your use is.
And it's really great for that.
And then, we have Google
Kubernetes engine.
And this is managed Kubernetes
on Google Compute Engine.
This is absolutely one
of the easiest ways
to get started with
containers and Kubernetes.
This is how I got started.
And it's really, really
good, because we take care
of a lot of the stuff for you.
While there's lots of folks
involved in the Kubernetes
project, both inside
and outside Google,
Google is still very involved.
And the team that builds
Google Kubernetes engine
works with the team that's
working on Kubernetes to make
sure that everything is smooth.
So we want to say thank you.
And before we actually say thank
you to you all for attending,
I would actually like to
really thank all the folks who
are making this possible.
We've got fantastic
staff running the lights
and running the camera
for the Livestream
and producing in this room.
So if you all could give
them a round of applause,
I'd be grateful.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you all for
coming and giving us
45 minutes of your wonderful
day today at Google I/O.
I hope you have a
wonderful afternoon.
MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]